the last time we've seen you you've
entered a new phase of life so
congratulations on the marriage um why
is cook the one why is he the one that
made you say Oh throwing that away well
he's just the best person I've ever met
in my whole life it was it was a very
easy easy decision she should be tough
did you hear what the kids are calling
you Phoenix
so sophie turner was joking with us
saying that she gave Maddie room been
dealing with this all day that's not
true then she gave him a seek the ending
that she feels like you really would
have won she absolutely did that's not a
lie that is true yes she really did okay
so you're happy with the way things
ended you're happy you're not gonna be
blue anymore other people I don't even
think I'll do like aging makeup ever
just nothing stop painting my face
except for this yeah I was I was blown
away really I mean they really did not
hold back with the ending of this movie
and it was quite emotional Simon told me
he had to cut a deal with you that you
would only be blue for like 2.6 seconds
and what if you watch this series of the
movies you see they're like writing
around my blue like the first movie I
ended like being like mutant and proud
and then the movie after that I was like
I changed my mind there's like I didn't
it's tough a long time in the makeup
chair
[Music]